bus the dangers of of MMA boxing how
many how many how dangerous is the game
in regards to people actually dying in
the game of MMA almost no zero almost no
yeah more why more boxing than it is in
MMA because boxing every boxing training
you do a lot of sparring and guess what
ninety percent of the punches go to the
head you know so you take a lot of
punishment into sparring already boxing
also the extreme weight Cuts also take
the flutes in your brain away which are
there for a reason to you know the
cushion the the airbag so they say the
water bag in this case uh so but
everything is focused on the head in MMA
you say oh yes they had a heart sparring
session they're striking let's go
wrestle today let's go to submission
today you see you can switch in between
and it's still a shape you still can use
it for the fight
have you followed the story of uh uh
Sugar Ray Robinson and is it Jimmy Doyle
do you know that story no do you know
the story Sugar Ray Robinson and Jimmy
Doyle this is very very interesting so
this is a fight back if you can Google
this Sugar Ray Robinson and Jimmy don't
go to go to uh go to all and see what
year this fight was uh zoom in uh go to
the date these guys fought in Cleveland
oh there it is go back right there they
fought in Cleveland June 25th 1947. so
here's what happens sugar Robinson is
fighting Jimmy Doyle the night before
Sugar Ray Robinson goes to sleep
has a nightmare that he punches Jimmy
doe with a left hand left punch and he
kills him do you know this story so he
comes in the morning Sugar Ray says I
don't want to fight this guy to the
pastor Catholic priest yeah he says why
he says last night I had a nightmare
that I killed him he says what are you
talking about so I'm telling you I don't
want to fight this guy I'm afraid I'm
going to kill this guy so they fight
sugar hits him with a left punch okay
falls to the ground
goes to the hospital the guy dies geez
you didn't know this no the guy dies by
the way when you hear him telling the
story Sugar Ray when he's telling the
story he's crying telling the story
the guy Jimmy was planning on taking
that money to buy a house for his mom
from the fight
when Jimmy dies Sugar Ray feels so bad
the next four fights he gives all the
money to Jimmy's mom wow and jit and
Sugar Ray for the rest of his life
he's afraid to throw the left when he's
fighting people yep you hear these types
of stories sometimes you're like man I
and you hear it more in the I mean you
you you hear it more in the boxing world
than you hear about it in in the MMA
world the ones that died were always com
uh companies that didn't have all the
checks you know like some company
somewhere where they didn't have CAT
scans and all that stuff because they
would get hit and then they found out
later that the guy had a weakest scholar
he had spots that were very weak you
know so and and the UFC Bellator all
these companies they they have so such a
thorough
uh body checks that it's okay yeah the
only reason I ask is because what's
what's more dangerous to get in the face
I mean you've got a punch or a kick or a
knee it's got to be the kick of course
that's what I'm saying right so if
you've got a knee or a kick and how come
no one in UFC has
died from a knee or a kick but they have
unboxing it blows me away and especially
if you get kicked by like a guy like
Miracle Crow cup yeah who did I say why
you should get so strong what is the
trick he says I do after a workout a
thousand kicks every time
thousand kicks you know it's like Bruce
Lee used to say he says I'm not worried
about the guy who knows 10 000 kicks I
know I'm worried about a guy who knows
one kick but did it ten thousand times
it's a scary kick yeah
the the guy from he would knock out
Bulls yeah like knocking out Bulls
That's How Strong a sponge was and when
they asked him in an interview
what do you want to get stronger in your
body he goes my parties okay see it's
never good enough so what all the
craziness taking place I believe future
looks bright if you believe future looks
bright get your latest Future looks
bright hat of valuetainment it says
future looks bright here future looks
bright here we got them in white we got
them in Black we got them in red are
black on black sold out these are about
to sell out if you haven't ordered one
yet we had a person in Michigan but one
then he bought three then when those
three people weren't in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody saying future looks
bright toward your future looks bright
hat click over here and to watch the
entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]